good morning and welcome to the daily
briefing at the European Union regional
task force operational area it is very
much helpful for all the agencies to be
here in the front line to share the same
office to cooperate better it is very
useful also for the Italian authorities
to have all the agencies on spot going
to the disembarkation place to address
them
for example front X is going that the
disembarkation port to do screening and
debriefing then when somebody says
asylum we referred them to Italian
authorities who are working together
with a so if there will be something
regarding investigation Europol we take
over so there is a very good connection
and a very important one we cooperate in
the sense of sharing information of
what's happening in the sense of
migrants coming in and also specifically
has the role of supporting the Italian
authorities in speeding up the
registration procedures the other value
of the hotspot is to be able to send
teams of experts made of experts coming
from the different member states and
giving the support to the Italian
authorities on the ground we need the
international level it's important when
an event an incident occurred when
Mayland arrived in Italy we try to find
that the facilitator of the margining go
in to arrest them
what Europol is responsible for for
aiding and supporting the italian
authorities in the activities of
investigating criminal groups organized
groups the objective of Europol is not
as much the migrants themselves but who
facilitates this kind of illegal
immigration so the organized crime
groups there are behind uniform and the
main goal is to disrupt the business
model of human smuggling at the traffic
networks on the sea yes in the
Mediterranean Sea there is a very good
collaboration and very good
cooperation we have the same mission
different means but the same mission and
this is the very important aspect of
this you RTF thank you for the
participation to the daily briefing and
we will see each other tomorrow thank
you very much